MELISSA NOBLES: Here,
our mission at MIT
is to apply knowledge
gained through research
to solve the world's
most pressing problems.
And we cannot do that without
scientists from historically
marginalized communities.
MONIQUE EARL-LEWIS: We want
education to be accessible.
We want it to be free.
We want it to be open.
And we want it to reflect the
communities in which people
serve, people learn,
and people teach.
ROBBIE MELTON: We
are now in a climate
where people are trying to limit
when you learn, how you learn,
and what you learn.
I'm here to promote OER,
Open Education Resources.
And open education
means exactly that.
It's open.
JEAN-JACQUES MEDASTIN:
OER means to me
that it is possible for
somebody who looks like me,
came from the same world as
I did to achieve something
that they never dreamed of.
It's accessibility.
It's freedom.
It's-- its gift.
It means the world to me.
And that's why I'm so excited.
I'm like, this is possible.
This is finally possible.
ROBBIE MELTON: You have three
powerful forces coming together
again, the HBCUs,
and MIT, Merlot.
The need is worldwide
for people of all races,
underrepresented populations to
be able to access information,
and to tap in to rich
cultural resources
to help them in their
academic journey.
MONIQUE EARL-LEWIS: There is no
one-size-fits all in education.
We have very different
and unique experiences
in terms of our histories,
our culture, our education,
our disciplines, but
we're finding ways
to connect the values
and goals that we
have that will benefit
not only the students
at our institution, but
institutions, faculty,
and students around the world.